foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
moment of the sexual experience would
ask the young lady who's your daddy this
should be remixed if officer akimov is
watching this could be the next remix
Masterpiece because just wait till you
see what happens here oh officer officer
akimov is here uh that's beautiful
[Music]
I'm joined today by Pastor James David
Manning
no I'm a Christian
[Music]
who's your daddy I'm joined today by
Pastor James David Manning
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
Earth to reverence the word of God to
trust it to preach it to teach it
Loaves and loads of money and tons and
tons of Life
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies what happened in prison
that brought you to Jesus
foreign
that brought you to Jesus
[Music]
George Bush Jr have been penetrated by
at least 100 men in their anus a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand strong I
didn't do it that's not my problem well
I got down on my knees
I didn't do it but I was tempted sounds
like quite an evening
[Music]
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of live
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of Life
nose and loads of money and tons and
tons of Lies
I didn't say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
Starbucks has done the exact same thing
that Coca-Cola has done except they've
done it we've seen them that certainly
is seems to be a story that has been
missed
[Music]
it's getting to love each other's semen
how do you know that it flavors the
coffee days tend to love each other's
semen
how do you know that it flavors the
coffee days tend to love each other's
semen
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mangoes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mango material
be affected
don't want me to
megaphone guy trespasses
wow and there it is it is one year since
the January 6th Trump riots we are
monitoring so many different things and
have so many things to go over Donald
Trump has been so heavily triggered by
Joe Biden's speech this morning
directly putting
significant blame for what happened one
year ago today on the former president
and we have so many different things to
go over first and foremost
we are standing by right now the
trumpists are doing a freedom rally
understand this in support okay I hope
you're sitting down in support of the
rioters they now care about conditions
in jail
this yeah the Republicans I'm saying
they now care about that and we are
standing by for some kind of rally in
support of the rioters and of trump and
it's going to be completely whacked off
the wall so that's number one number two
we are monitoring what's happening in
Washington DC a heavier police presence
expected both at the Capitol and at the
White House and really everywhere so far
it has not been riotous and that's a
really good thing so we are monitoring
that we are going to look at Donald
Trump's various statements he's just
been tweeting statement after statement
today
we are going to be looking at uh the Joe
Biden speech as I mentioned we have a
variety of different clips of it we are
going to be looking at the moment one
year ago where we all were here I have
not been able to pinpoint the exact
moment where the riot started but we are
going to sort of revisit the slow
realization about what was going on that
was a year ago today many of you were
here for that we will look at the
counter statement uh Congress people
Matthew Gates and Marjorie Taylor green
held a press conference rebutting Joe
Biden's speech today we're going to be
looking at that we have uh oh statements
from Liz Harrington yep uh Mitch
McConnell put out a statement as well
and did not even mention Donald Trump in
talk how do you talk about the riots and
not not mention Trump which is just
crazy and as I mentioned we have the Joe
Biden clip so a lot of insanity going on
look at this they are rallying here in
support of the rioters
um let's take a just a brief listen to
this
across the state and maybe all across
the country have gathered in support of
President Trump as well as the political
prisoners being held in DC gitmo very
sick it's a relate to January 6. we all
know what's going on in the country
right now as far as the media and
Democrats all right so we're going to
keep an eye on that and see sort of what
happens there we do have super chats
working on the screen today none have
been sent yet but if you look at the
bottom of the screen here we're
currently YouTube chat is going by
there's Mike McGee there's a super chat
from Mike McGee let me just tweak this
to get it on screen there it is folks
there it is and we have beautiful
beautiful super chats so they will
display as far as I know uh whoa hold on
a second something crazy just happened
there it is there it is there it is so
we're still working on a more permanent
solution for super chats but they will
display thanks to Mike McGee for the
4.99 uh Super Chat okay but oh wait hold
on they're interviewing a guy let's see
what he's saying if it weren't for right
side broadcasting a few minutes ago you
asked me when I got that little birdie
in my ear well I just got it so my
suggestion is you guys make your way
over to the French barricades because
you're going to be surprised so you have
a place in mind you think we should go
near the barricade right over anywhere
anywhere along the barricades is good
all right anywhere along the barricades
okay we're gonna make our way over here
first perfect side broadcasting thank
you okay so this is a very sick cult
these people are all out of their minds
it's an illness extreme significant
illness so we're going to be monitoring
that
um hot mustard gas says I was watching
your stream when this happened many of
us were here a year ago indeed indeed
indeed indeed
um very much appreciate that uh okay let
me just get a couple thank yous out of
the way I do want to say thanks to
Rebecca Rebecca Veith who just signed up
at joinpakman.com and is new member
number one I want to remind you guys of
two things number one the coupon code
Obama oh wait a second where did that go
uh ah there it is number one coupon code
Obama Obama is working but we have a
special code today and that code is
please no Riot you might remember that a
year ago we had that coupon code please
no Riot we didn't want a riot and that
code is still working also I want to
thank every single one of you who has
signed up and supported us via twitch
and that includes micro
tampst the old tired Road
Cosmos Mad Max
kyoshike Bic Marcus pink and blonde
nanor mom Roy that's 10. and TR napsta
is 11 11 plus one one plus one is two
nothing to carry that puts us at 12 and
we will open phone lines if we were to
get to 100 very very much appreciate
that I'm Mikey says via Super Chat Mr
Pacman sir would you say that your
coupon code
is a form of mass formation psychosis
aimed at making people
take advantage of incredible deals I
would say so I don't even know what I'm
doing sir yeah I would say that for sure
very very good point Derek says via
Super Chat David sir did you see the
Newsweek article about Special Forces
with shoot to kill orders on the capitol
uh on one six I did not
that is not an element of news that I
have seen so far but I am very very open
to seeing it big thanks to Erica scungio
for signing up on my website with the
coupon code Obama
Erica's new member number 13 today also
thanks to Brown coat Loki Carly Knight
The rient Goat as well numbers 14 15 and
16. now I do have to make a disclaimer
as super chats are pouring in
you guys hear that
that's tree work being done it's been
going on outside of our studio for three
days
I am looking to shut it down
but of course it's completely legal so
really I'm just a curmudgeon for
complaining uh I'm glad if you guys
don't hear it I did see it show up on my
level meter but it's completely toxic
leaf blowers and tree work elements are
some of the most vile noises so we're
going to work around it Amit says David
sir I appreciate you quoting all of
Trump's superlative strongly powerful
but I believe you're not giving credit
to former VP pens and his tendency of
saying that everything is broad
shoulders yeah uh Pence likes to say
that it's a broad shouldered initiative
I like that Wendy says I would
foreign
you guys have to be hearing that right
okay anyway fine hey better
Wendy says I was here a year ago was
shocked by what I saw thanks for doing
this Pedro says interesting segment on
covid testing denialism the other day by
the way Carrie Mullis can't weigh in
since he died in 2019 he was also an
AIDS denialist yeah
this interview makes me want to bash my
head against the wall
as a Canadian for the first time ever I
see articles in our papers how Canada
should deal with a U.S dictatorship I
covered that earlier this week what was
your opinion on Merrick Garland's speech
yesterday I think that the words were
very strong and I wonder whether there
will be any action behind it all right
let's listen just another second here no
no
young people we want money we come here
for Tom and we're for America we're very
nice that's I'm sure enough guys the
memory on Earth last year on you know
January [ __ ] okay very very sick very
very sick okay let's go to the moment
let's relive the moment this is sort of
starting where things were starting to
go crazy
uh oh I don't think my hairlines changed
in the last year that's that's a good
sign this was one year ago today
remember this guys Cyril elected
Republicans who are openly trying to
execute a coup for the president in an
election that they lost and at the same
time the supporters of that president
who lost are physically trying to break
in
to the U.S Capitol Building there they
are actually up the steps and at a door
and it is conceivable that they will be
able to break their way in this is a
guys I almost think my hairline's better
this year than last year I hate to say
it but Global embarrassment
this sets absolutely insane precedent
for the future of the United States and
there is no possible way to overstate
how crazy this is so anybody what what I
don't know what you want me to do
if you want me to start you know
punching my microphone or bashing my
head into the this is uh this is a
tragedy of unspeakable proportions
happening to to American democracy and
it's happening during a hundred year
pandemic
um and we'll and there's people
everywhere with no masks
um this is a uh this this is what I mean
listen is it is it crazy to say failed
state
or or a would-be failed State like in
other words Biden will eventually be
president
if the National Guard has to come out
they will remember remember this was at
1 pm little did we know that there would
be a point made to prevent the National
Guard from coming out which they could
have I was talking about the National
Guard at 1 pm here but if they got their
way it would be a failed State like
right if these guys got their way
and then these guys got their way it
would be a failed state
um there's there's no question about
that uh but hopefully we will be able to
resist that but I would be very careful
if I was in Washington DC right now
I don't know if any of these people have
jobs that's a fair question
that's an absolutely fair question
um many of them lost their jobs in the
aftermath I mean that's another aspect
of this if they do you know I guess they
can
afford to take the day off but they are
pushing and pushing and trying to breach
that door and as you can see the scrum
continues to advance remember now we
have the benefit of hindsight of all
that happened at this point we were like
oh they're Gathering oh they're pushing
up oh they're trying to get in little
did we know what was ultimately going to
happen on that day towards the door uh
I do want to say thank you to everybody
who who's watching
um very special shout out to everybody
watching on Twitch we've committed to
Twitch for 2021 and we're here and I
held that commitment
I held that commitment and I really
appreciate a lot of good points being
made by the way in this stream everybody
who's been signing up and uh there's an
additional 16 folks who just grabbed
twitch Subs so let's skip ahead I don't
know 20 minutes and see how much crazier
it got by then this is 16 minutes later
they have been streaming into the U.S
Capitol media reports are that they
don't know where police are sometimes
describing one guys look at this with
the benefit of hindsight we were saying
where are the police well there was a
reason the police weren't there sir
sometimes describing or overwhelmed
there were police there of course
handcuffs left on the ground unclear the
significance of that and uh this is
partially a group of people these uh
protesters who came over from a trump
event hours ago apparently many of them
clarity about who these people were I
mean it's it's it's actually crazy to
think back about how much we didn't
really know
but our suspicions were all completely
correct needing to use the bathroom now
because they've been at the Trump rally
and then now now they are here but uh
this is rapidly becoming a situation
completely out of control and I don't
know from the standpoint of law
enforcement what is being waited for I
don't know right at some point we are
going to see military show up here and I
understand the point of trump isn't
going to deploy to the military against
his own supporters it is not just up to
Trump to activate either National Guard
or federal military so we hoped assets
that is not the only way that it can
happen and there is the hypothesis being
made by some of the people in my
audience that this is all a pretext on
which uh to Stage uh to denounce to
announce martial law uh questions as to
whether a curfew will be announced in
Washington DC to put some end to this at
some point in time uh I have never
experienced anything like this I have
never experienced anything like this the
entire process of counting the ballots
typically meant to be perfunctory has
been look at this this is when they
started getting in down all of these
folks you see here have physically
breached the U.S capital let's listen we
have learned now that the as you can see
the protesters have breached the capital
they're inside they're crossing over
Statuary Hall which is separates the
chamber that separates the house and the
Senate as you can see they've made their
way over into the house side some of
them on the house side some on the
Senate side right outside these Chambers
don't tell me they're getting into the
chamber oh yeah who has covered Capitol
Hill from oh they were David they were
many years is joining us in a year we'll
do a stream covering this stream
covering that stream and then we'll do
it once a year the phone Niels do we
know how it is that they were able to
get inside the capitol that was a great
question well from uh my vantage point
away from the hill I I don't know
exactly
which door or doors they were able to
breach but there were clearly uh
protesters uh and and violent protesters
who uh appear to have breached at least
one of the doorways if not multiple of
the Capitol building itself uh and and
so there has been uh there were efforts
at locking down uh the building but but
quite frankly all right and then let's
just you know we're not going to do this
all day but let's skip ahead a little
bit here uh and look at the you know
this is just thinking back to how crazy
it was and now there's there are so this
is continued to be a
uh developing situation and at this
point I think that the immediate the
immediate concern is with the uh use of
weapons and and and sort of this being
Beyond
a peaceful protest we left yeah by the
90-minute Mark we were thinking this may
not be a peaceful protest a time ago oh
my God we're just continuing to see all
right let's get back to PBS and we're
hearing some sort of alarm go off Elisa
if you're there we'll stay with you we
do want you to stay safe oh my God Lisa
can you tell whether they've been able
to get close to go ahead Lisa
yeah Capital police are now on the floor
they are now working to secure this war
protesters that go on the ground
[Music]
behind me
all right
we're hearing shouts in the background
Lisa we want you to stay safe we're
gonna come away for just a moment until
we can understand
a little more about what's going on
trying to understand whether they've
been able to get into the house Chambers
and of course knowing whether the men go
ahead Lisa go ahead
please have told me to stay down and
that's what I'm doing oh my God
I also don't want to show a video this
this apple is an area that is usually
prohibited from showing video that's why
I've been selected and shooting video
nothing
the capital is operating under any sort
of rules at the moment I want to try and
be respectful while reporting this
extraordinary moment in American history
the police do think the police have
gained control for the moment of this
Corridor the capital I'm no longer hear
protesters
chanting beneath me in Statuary Hall
where they have been but I do hear
shouting as Greece seem to one by one
be taken down all right so that was a
year ago today guys that was a year ago
today and uh quite uh quite quite a
situation and after all that this is
what Trump supporters are doing today
they are rallying in West Palm Florida
or Palm Beach Florida or West Palm Beach
Florida or you know whatever the the
central Palm all these different things
they are rallying in support of the
rioters who they are referring to as
political prisoners
that's what's going on right now as a
result of that it is absolutely insane
super chat's coming in uh no jail for
orange you said any consequences
I don't expect any real consequences for
Trump no
your coverage of this last year was how
I found your channel sir now I'm back in
the very same room still watching one
year later full circle great to have you
here I appreciate that that you are here
let me say thank you before we continue
uh onto the gates green stuff and then
the Biden stuff and then the Trump
statements there's so much to cover
today I want to say thanks to people who
have been signing up on my website it's
it's really the best way to support the
work we do I want to say thanks to Jason
Steele who signed up with the coupon
code Obama
Dylan Richardson signed up with the
coupon code oh Obama
dine Christensen signed up with the
coupon code
and Matthew patlin signed up with the
coupon code please no Riot that's for
putting us at uh 20.
20 for the day also want to make sure
I'm keeping up with everybody supporting
on Twitch and that includes let me make
sure I got everybody's names right
um Brown coat Loki Carly Knight The
rient Goat drewish
Brown coat Loki with a gift this is Fadi
k
ittle stew Savvy lemons hey it's Damien
that's nine nine plus twenty nine and
zero is nine and two is two puts us at
29.
Aaron says is the right way in the right
wing propaganda film capital punishment
they said the capital was breached at 12
45 during the Trump speech implying it
was not Maga listen I don't I don't have
the exact timeline in front of me right
now but um it it was Maga it was Maga I
think that that's all very very clear to
us at this point
um the cognitive dissonance between it
was antifa and happy Insurrection day
coming from the same people is
astounding yeah also astounding is it
was completely peaceful and it was
antifa well then what are we worried
about it was peaceful antifa that those
seemed to be sort of uh in Conflict all
right let's go to clips now of Joe Biden
this was Joe Biden this was Biden's best
speech ever
you could say well but David sir it's a
low bar
and you're not necessarily wrong sir but
it was Biden's best speech and let's
look at a couple of clips of it this is
from today
what do we not see
we didn't see a former president
who had just rallied the mob to attack
sitting in a private dining room off the
Oval Office in the white house watching
it all on television
and doing nothing
for hours
as police were assaulted
lives at risk
the nation's capital Under Siege yeah
this wasn't a group of tourists
this was an armed insurrection
they weren't looking to everybody from
aristocracy TV with the raid uh on
Twitch welcome everybody uphold the will
of the people they were looking to deny
the will of the people right they were
looking uphold they weren't looking to
hold a free and fair election they were
looking to overturn one
then we're looking to save
the cause of America
they were looking to subvert the
Constitution
this isn't about being bogged down in
the past
it's about making sure the past isn't
buried
that's the only way forward right that's
what great Nations do
they don't bury the truth
they face up to it sounds like hyperbole
but that's the truth they face up to it
we are a great nation not a joke
my fellow Americans
in life there's truth
and tragically there are lies
lies conceived and spread for profit and
Power
we must be absolutely clear about what
is true and what is a lie
and here's the truth
the former president of the United
States of America
has created and spread a Web of Lies
about the 2020 election
he's done so because he values power
over principle
because he sees his own interest
is more important than his country's
interest than America's interest
and because his bruised ego
matters more to him than our democracy
or our constitution he can accept he
lost a very very good speech by Joe
Biden maybe I love the energy maybe the
time of day I mean this was a morning
speech maybe that's better I don't know
but it was excellent
um
thanks to nadius Maximus as well as
Bowflex man for the twitch Prime
subscriptions appreciate that super
chats are coming in did I see the video
that the Lincoln project made out of
Biden's speech today I haven't seen that
yet
the strangest tour I've ever seen these
must be the same curious mind suddenly
concerned with preserving history in the
form of Confederate statues and Patrick
says enough about your hair I think we
haven't talked about my hair in a half
an hour let's continue with Joe Biden's
speech here very very good speech today
and so at this moment we must decide
what kind of nation are we going to be
are we going to be a nation that accepts
political violence as a norm right
are we going to be a nation
or we allow partisan election officials
to overturn
the legally expressed will of the people
almost are you going to be a nation that
lives Not By the Light of the truth
and the shadow of Lies
we cannot allow ourselves to be that
kind of nation
The Way Forward is to recognize the
truth
and to live by it
the big lie being told by the former
president and many Republicans who fear
his Wrath
is that the Insurrection in this country
actually took place on Election Day
November three or third
2020. think about that
is that what you thought no is that what
you thought when you voted that day with
all durers
that what you thought you were doing
or did you think you're carrying out
your highest Duty as a citizen and
voting
former presidential supporters are
trying to rewrite history
they want you to see election day as the
day of insurrection
and the right that took place here on
January 6th as a true expression
of the will of the people
can you think of a more Twisted way to
look at this country to look at America
it's pretty sick pretty sick let's
continue taken long after the election
in several States
none change the results
and in some of them the irony is the
margin of Victory actually grew slightly
that's true
so let's speak plainly about what
happened in 2020.
even before the first ballot was cast
the former president was preemptively
sowing doubt about the election results
he built his lie over months
wasn't based any facts
he was just looking for an excuse a
pretext
to cover for the truth
she's not just a former president
he's a defeated former president
[Laughter]
um here is real a really really good
point made in this next clip by Joe
Biden where he talks about you know how
I've been talking for a while about
these right Wingers they have their
principles which they say these are our
principles but then they abandon the
principles as soon as they're
inconvenient let businesses do what's
best for them
don't regulate them
well but if they want to require
vaccination then don't let them do that
and if Twitter wants to ban Marjorie
Taylor green then don't let them do but
I thought your principle was well no no
that's different now and and Joe Biden
applies it bigger picture here
you can't love your country only when
you win
you can't obey the law only when it's
convenient right you can't be patriotic
when you Embrace and enable lies
those who storm this capital
and those who instigated and incited
and those who called on them to do so
held a dagger at the throat of America
if you're joining and you're wondering
what the background noise is it was a
chainsaw from three days of toxic tree
work going on half a block away they now
I can tell just from the noise I can
identify all these all these elements
now they're using the chipper
to make mulch out of the tree that
they've just taken down so it's we're I
apologize for those who are um who are
wearing headphones or whatever and can
hear that I see that my microphone is
picking it up but it is slight Erica an
American democracy
they didn't come here out of patriotism
or principle
they came here in Rage
not in service of America
but rather in service of one man
those who incited the mob
the real plotters who were desperate to
deny the certification of this election
defy the will of the voters
but their plot was foiled
Congressman Democrats and Republicans
stayed fortunately uh all right and then
here is the last clip uh Joe Biden
winding down the speech very his best
speech without a doubt his best speech
is President oh thanks to bionic bill
for the twitch Prime subscription you're
number 32 today thanks Bill destruction
is Vice President of referenced in Pearl
Harbor
can the triumph over the forces of
fascism
from the brutality of Bloody Sunday
and the Edmund Pettus Bridge
became historic voting rights
legislation
so now let's step up
write the next chapter in American
history
January 6 marks not the end of democracy
the beginning of a Renaissance of
Liberty and fair play
I did not seek this fight
brought to this Capital one year ago
today
but I will not shrink from it either
I will stand in this breach I will
defend this nation not allow no one to
place a dagger at the throat of
democracy
we will make sure the will of the people
that's heard
that the battle prevails not violence
that Authority in this nation will
always
be peacefully transferred
I believe the power of the presidency
and the purpose is to unite this nation
not divided so Lift us up not tear us
apart
it's about us about us not about me
deep in the heart of America Burns a
flame but almost 250 years ago
of Liberty freedom and equality
this is not a land of Kings or dictators
all right so I think you guys get it
just a few more seconds there and Biden
wraps up I mean he really said
everything the only thing he could have
added would have been the following
that would have made it an absolutely
perfect speech all right people asking
about the wood chipper there's wood
chipping going on right outside the
studio it's been going on for three days
it's it's actually it's it's legit it
should be against the law it should be
against the law what's going on out
there don't they realize we're producing
a show here okay
um super chats yeah super chats are
coming up on the screen long time
listener says John now a subscriber due
to Biden's Administration and student
loan forbearance we are watching with
you during the riot and are here with
you to put it all to bed thank you John
Hopper says Newsweek article secret
Commandos with shoot to kill Authority
were at the Capitol yeah let's look at
the article because a lot of people are
asking me to look at that and then we'll
move on to the Trump response and then
we'll get the Taylor green response and
there's so many things okay exclusive
shoot to kill Authority secret Commandos
were at the Capitol this is from a
couple days ago on January 3rd the heads
of a half dozen Elite government special
ops teams met in Quantico Virginia to go
over potential threats contingencies and
plans for the upcoming joint session of
Congress the meeting and subsequent
deployment of these shadowy Commandos on
January 6th has never before been
revealed now do they mean this year or
last year let's see if it says right
after the New Year Jeffrey Rosen acting
AG improved implementation of
long-standing contingency plans dealing
with the most extreme possibilities oh
last year an attack on Trump or Pence
a terrorist attack involving a weapon of
mass destruction
and a declaration of measures to
implement continuity of government
requiring protection and movement of
presidential success successors Rosen
made a unilateral decision to take
Preparatory steps to deploy justice
department and so-called National forces
there was no formal request from Capitol
Police Secret Service or Metropolitan
Police no external request from any
agency the leaders in Justice and the
FBI anticipated the worst and decided to
act independently the special ops force
is lurking behind the scenes
the contingency units meeting on January
3rd including FBI's HRT FBI's National
render safe team FBI SWAT
and other organizations
all of these assets were pre-deployed
and ready to go the weekend of January
2-3
staging out of the FBI Academy in
Quantico if a wmd or terrorist attack
occurred the units were to move via
helicopter to the site of the incident
the activation of the catastrophic
response units operating under plans
already approved by Trump entailed an
automatic green light allowing Federal
responders to take the initiative and
spare no resources including shoot to
kill authority to deal with this most
extraordinary condition this is quite an
article this is um this is news to me
so I'm going to read more about it and
then maybe maybe do a segment on it if
it comes to it so we've seen Joe Biden's
speech earlier today and we're going to
now go to Donald Trump's reactions
meanwhile trumpists are rallying today
in support of the rioters of the rioters
let's listen a little bit and I'm going
to tell you
Ben I
had a podcaster I just wasn't that
wasn't my calling that wasn't my purpose
travel state to state seeking truth
speaking truth and my grandfathers were
both war heroes so
I'm not interested in what this guy is
saying let me say a few other thank yous
big big big thank you to Mark bowling
who just signed up on my website with
the coupon code Obama Obama
Don Gladden just signed up on my website
with the coupon code please no Riot
Laurie radek just signed up with the
coupon code wow 22 and Donald Hewitt
just signed up with the coupon code
wow22 that puts us at 36. now I have
something else to mention Jackson just
made a patreon pledge those count double
today which puts us at 38 and then I
also want to say thanks over on Twitch
too
um let me see here bionic Bill robot
laser party ristocrat Perma hex Knights
over Egypt Soul knife and zero cool have
made twitch Prime subscriptions which
puts us at 45 and I really appreciate
that other super chats coming in Mason
says let's Riot towards the wood chipper
people then blame it on antifa January 6
wood chipper Edition it sounds like
they're winding down with the wood
chipper let me listen
it's still running but it's not actively
chipping right now
so let's uh let's hope that that's uh
that that's sort of the worst of it okay
let's go to oh I know Gremlin is
pointing out something I'm not
pronouncing wow 22. so the coupon code
wow22 you're you're actually supposed to
pronounce it wow 22.
wow 22. but you know okay
uh all right let's get to Donald Trump's
responses Donald Trump was so treasured
as some say others say triggered by Joe
Biden's direct full frontal assault on
him this morning
that he put out a series of increasingly
deranged statements one really funny
aspect of this is that since he's banned
from Twitter
he has the spokeswoman Liz Harrington
who publishes them
she takes screenshots of these and
publishes them which is all pretty funny
but we're not going to look at them
there we're going to look at them on
Trump's website so let's go through
these statements from it is essentially
ban evasion that's absolutely true it is
a band evasion statement by Scrump due
to inept leadership that gave us open
borders covet incompetence loss of
energy Independence a military in chaos
rampant inflation corrupt elections and
lack of world standing our nation
perhaps for the first time has lost its
confidence now we could take each of
these
things one by one and kind of debunk
them uh you know border policy has not
substantively changed since Trump left
covet incompetence I mean listen there's
been Global incompetence in the sense
that this thing is completely out of
control loss of energy Independence
nothing has substantively changed with
energy in the U.S the military is no
more in chaos now than it was under
Trump inflation is high but it has very
little to do with presidents corrupt
elections no
and lack of world standing is the most
weaponized the U.S reputation globally
is better now than it was under Trump
look at any poll Gallop Pew any of them
and it'll show you that that's number
one second statement Trump now talking
about Biden more specifically Biden who
is destroying our nation with insane
policies of open borders look at how he
capitalizes borders corrupt elections
capitalized e disastrous energy policy
this is like a rehash of the previous
one
unconstitutional mandates devastating
school closures used my name today to
try to further divide America
this political theater is all just the
distraction for the fact Biden is
completely and totally failed our
Capital C country no longer has capital
B borders it's true borders closed since
he's using a capital B I can only assume
he means that old book like it's like a
Barnes and Noble that's what he means
since it's capitalized right we don't
have borders anymore they closed
okay well maybe they mean something
different has totally and completely
lost control of kovid is no longer
energy independent like look at these
random caps inflation is rampant our
militaries and Chaos our exit or
Surrender from Afghanistan was the most
embarrassing day in the long and
distinguished history of the U.S
remember Trump had no better plan for
getting out would have been chaos no
matter when we got out
why is it that the unselect committee of
totally partisan hacks whose judgment
has long ago been made not discussing
the rigged presidential election of
2020. so you know just another one of
these triggered statements Democrats
want to own this day of January 6th so
they can Stoke fears and divide I say
let them have it
because America sees through their lies
and polarizations
all right statement number three Biden
is working hard to try and deflect the
incompetent job he is doing and has done
on the horrible Afghanistan withdrawal
surrender the borders covet inflation
loss of energy Independence it's the
same statement guys this is he's
basically it's the same statement
everything he touches turns to failure
that's what you get when you have a
rigged election it's just like a rehash
of the same thing
and then fourthly this huge one to watch
Biden speaking is very hurtful to many
people they're the ones who tried to
stop the peaceful transfer with a rigged
election just look at the numbers does
anybody really think Biden beat Obama
with the black population and select
swing state cities but nowhere else that
he would lose 18 out of 19 Bellwether
counties and 27 out of 27 toss-up house
races but miraculously received the most
votes in American history with no
coattails that he would lose Florida
Ohio and Iowa and win even though it has
never been done before
it's funny when Trump does things that
have never been done before
it's a testament to how great Trump is
when Biden does things that have never
been done before it's obviously a fraud
it's all crazy and he's just continuing
to lie where did the votes show up in
Georgia all this different stuff capping
it with never forget the crime of the
2020 presidential election never give up
just a word salad it's diarrhea of the
mouth
diarrhea of the of the text I guess I
don't know
um so those those were Trump's reactions
and each more unhinged than the previous
let's go back and see how the rally in
support of the rioters is going in
Florida while we get ready to move on to
Gates and green I want to tell you how
you can support us and keep this this
network going you guys we are like rest
in peace Ashley Babbitt what uh
significant
that is small dollar donations we don't
take money from Big billionaires and
people that want to try to dictate what
we say on air we take money from you wow
it's an insane situation there okay
other super chats coming in in Virginia
we'd be thrilled to hear wood chopping
thousands still without power due to
Fallen trees after snow thanks for
always using logic and reason uh my
pleasure dexy appreciate that let me say
a big thank you and welcome to Ryan
Benson Ryan just signed up on my website
with the coupon code wow 22 and his new
member number 46 also thanks to John for
the five dollar patreon pledge patreon
counts double today so John you were
number 47 and 48 and over on Twitch I
want to say thank you to actually no
nobody on Twitch
nobody on Twitch but welcome welcome to
everybody who's watching okay let's move
oh by the way yeah I've been told that I
don't mention one of the best benefits
of being a member on my website which is
you get the whole show six hours earlier
like five hours early instead of having
to wait for these individual Clips to
publish to YouTube or waiting for the 9
p.m full show to publish usually between
2 30 and 3 P.M Eastern you've got the
entire show I I've been told that's like
the biggest benefit there's a there's a
Reddit post about it I I mean I if
that's what the people say then then by
all means that's what it is
um and uh you can sign up at
joinpakman.com before we move on I want
to remind you guys that on Tuesday
at 6 PM eastern time we will have the
first chess tournament of 2022 this is a
free community event I'm selling nothing
here other than a good time if you want
to pre-register
go to davidpackman.com chess it'll take
you to ourchess.com uh chess group just
become part of the club and then Tuesday
at 6 PM Eastern you'll be able to join
the tournament this is totally free
you'll be matched with people of your
level we've got some great people who
are going to be playing I will be
playing a grand master Benjamin Feingold
will be playing women's fee day Master
Anna kramling will be playing
um uh International Master Eric Rosen
will be playing and I have invites out
to a bunch of other people including
Levy Rosman and I invited uh Anna
Rudolph and we'll see who else is able
to play so it's just a community event
it's not it's I'm not selling you guys
anything it's just going to be fun is
vegan producer Pat gonna play maybe
maybe uh davidpackman.com chess will
take you here just join the club this is
all free it's all free free free and
um the tournament will start it'll only
run about 75 to 90 minutes you can play
part of it you can play all of it it's
going to be fun I'm going to be
streaming Tuesday 6 p.m Eastern Time
davidpackman.com
chess very very exciting stuff
um oh I'm being told this woman's nuts
let's listen
[Music]
so funny you know Kamala Harris about
three or four weeks ago do you think
they deliberately mispronounced Kamala
at this point there's a lot of horns
honking oh I did invite the bowtest
sisters they're unavailable on that day
God asked who's really in control
because it doesn't seem like it's
fighting and you know what she told him
she said
don't start acting like a republican
because he was questioning he had a
legit question I watched that she heard
the whole conversation because hey this
isn't Amy Schumer is it that's not who
this is right is there a resemblance
here I'm not super familiar with Amy
Schumer but I have a feeling that this
is a resemblance here uh
uh to
[Music]
Pamela that was um so she says camela
this guy says Kamala they're both wrong
[Music]
sure people knew who the the interviewer
is thinking of heading for the hills I
think he's regretting engaging here
president
[Music]
[Applause]
and the reason why the reason why I
bring that up that Kamala Harris
interview on The Breakfast Club the
reason why it's so significant is
because he's not a conservative he's not
a republican but he represents a lot of
people who voted for Biden and they
noticed what he noticed and that's like
he doesn't look like it's the blind
leading the blind here it's the blind
leading the blind it's truly shocking I
want to say thanks to Jacob Veo who just
signed up with the coupon code wow 22
and his new member number 49 today also
thank you to hammer Warfare B Kimberly
Upstate trash pepper love legally
blacked all of whom geez all of whom has
signed up on Twitch putting us at 54. it
is getting very very edgy here all right
let's go now to we're still keeping an
eye on the White House things looking
calm in Washington DC let's go over to
we already did the Biden stuff here is
if you can imagine it here is the
Republican response
oh no the wood Chipper's getting going
again here is the Republican response to
Joe Biden's speech today
they're wood shipping again let's listen
government may have been involved we
know this January 6 last year wasn't an
Insurrection no one's been charged with
Insurrection no one has been charged
with treason
but it very very well may have been a
Fed selection
we are very concerned that we have sent
letter after letter to attorney general
Garland and you guys don't write that's
not believable Matt that's not
believable the eye director Ray to
Simply get to the bottom of unexplained
circumstances where people are on the
FBI Most Wanted list from January 6th
and then they fall off of that list
uh FBI director Ray was asked under oath
before the Congress about the federal
assets and agents that were on the
ground on January 6 and he wouldn't
provide clear answers
attorney general Garland was asked in
the Judiciary Committee by my colleague
Thomas Massey about Ray Epps he could
have cleared up that circumstance and
resolved these questions imagine this
being the response to what Biden said
but he declined to do so it seems that
senior officials in our justice
department have no problem giving long
speeches to try to politically Target
and smear those they disagree with but
they don't answer the questions that can
get to the truth of what really happened
on January 6th elements I want to credit
the reporting at revolver news
[Laughter]
that now that's funny that's really
funny the videos that I'm going to go
through now that I think uh continue
remember revolver news is do you guys
remember that completely unhinged day
where Tucker Carlson said that the FBI
did the Trump riots he quoted a revolver
news article which doesn't cite anything
about the FBI involvement in these very
deep concerns that congresswoman green
and I have and I would ask you to play
the first class up they have clips
[Music]
[Music]
I think they're saying that that guy's
really an FBI agent is right is that
what they're saying
now don't aren't FBI agents forced to
retire at age 55 like doesn't this guy
look a little older than 55
I don't know
the powers of the federal government to
understand why Ray Epps the evening of
the fifth is out telling people
dispassionately professionally with
laser focus that the objective is to
enter lasers hope is not a Jewish space
laser on the sixth it's not the proud
boys who engage in the initial breach
it's Ray ups at that precise moment now
Ray Epps was originally on the FBI's
list of most Wanted individuals after uh
the the initial events on January 6th
but then the day after revolver news
publishes an explosive report about
Stuart Rhodes Who's involved with The
Oath Keepers then all of a sudden rayaps
his name falls off the list we've sent
letters asking questions about that
unexplainable circumstance and the FBI
and the justice department have given us
no Illuminating uh this is really a game
changer huh
um all right let's get to the Marjorie
green Taylor part of it and see what's
up with her unheard and we did not want
today's historical narrative to be
hijacked and captured by those who were
the true insurrectionists congresswoman
green
thank you very much why is Green's
physical appearance so revolting like I
I know that it's sort of outside the
bounds of political discourse but what
is it it's just it's revolting
and I I think that's that's credible
point
that Congressman Gates just
very important for the Republican voice
to go to to be heard today because it's
the Republican voice and the Republican
voter and the Trump supporter that has
been smeared constantly over this past
year I want you all to know that on the
real victims are the Trump supporters
yeah six I was very upset with what
happened that day and it was because it
completely interrupted the work that we
had worked very hard on all throughout
Christmas
um you know that this is this is a new
thing Peter Navarro said this in the
Yari melber interview
which was the riot got in the way of us
stealing the election were it not for
the riot maybe Mike Pence would have
like ceded other electors or would that
that's a com it disrupted the coup
exactly uh preparing for January 6 to
object on behalf of Americans right that
felt their boats had been stolen and I
think it's important to recognize that
our own Federal Election Commission
hasn't the facts don't care about your
feelings people felt that the election
had been stolen wow pretty convincing
you're right by law that is point zero
zero zero eight percent and it's
important to point out that elections
are very serious and they're taken that
way right by all Americans right don't
forget that Bernie Sanders felt that his
election was stolen by Hillary Clinton
don't forget that that's extraordinarily
deceptive because what what Bernie has
said about Hillary is not that the
election was fraudulent in this way
right I mean Bernie correct me if I'm
wrong guys Bernie said he felt as though
the entire primary was structured to be
beneficial to Hillary Clinton back in
2016. it's it's there's no equivalency
whatsoever between these two things
Hillary Clinton forgot that her election
Clinton but Clinton was stolen and I'll
tell you being from Georgia Stacey
Abrams still thinks she won in 2018 and
she's running again but here's some
things that we do need to discuss you
know I'm one of those people and I'm not
shy to tell you I don't trust our
government and that's another reason why
I ran for Congress is because I felt
like it's our government that is
screwing thing up everything up for the
American people but after what we've
seen on January 6 and the videos that
Congressman Gates just walked through I
can tell you right now I don't trust our
government even more wow when I didn't
when I went through the DC jail I'll
tell you who I did not see I did not see
Ray Epps I didn't see him in there
wasting away for months on end remember
guys the charged trumpists are the
victims here that's their position and
when we see what's going on in Florida
right now this is all in support of the
rioters
okay provide his due process rights
being denied the ability to see his
family to get medical treatment to get a
haircut and shave I didn't see him in
there you know who else I didn't see I
didn't see a man named John Sullivan a
man that has participated in antifa BLM
riots and the whole entire movement but
then all of a sudden decided to be a
trump supporter on January 6th right
same guy that was in the Capitol and
filmed Ashley Babbitt's murder and then
sold his videos to Media Outlets that's
a lot that's That's Heavy not in the DC
jail under under Deputy Warden Kathleen
landerkin so I think we have a lot of
questions to ask and the people that
should be answering the questions is our
FBI imagine like taking this seriously
as a reporter and you show up you're
like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna seriously
listen to what she says and we're gonna
follow up on these things
how do you even how do you even fact
check the things that she's saying
they're they're completely off the wall
unhinged
Justice I want to point some things out
to you all with the U.S capital Riot
there is over 725 arrests that I know of
yes and only one case has been dropped
for BLM antifa riots there were over 16
240 rest and over 90 percent of those
cases have been dropped so you have to
understand like
it the reason it's so hard to fact just
fact check this stuff on the go is okay
she says 16 000 people were arrested and
a ton of the cases were dropped and and
nobody's been dropped with this stuff
we have to understand is there were
thousands of people on January 6th in DC
and most of them were never even charged
now with the BLM antifa George Floyd
stuff there's no doubt that there were a
bunch of different arrests for different
things but a lot of those were like Mass
arrests of a bunch of people at the time
for being in a place they weren't
supposed to be it's like the way Jane
Fonda gets arrested I'm not denying
there was destruction of property there
was those people are being handled in a
different way but what happened at a lot
of those protests is a bunch of people
were given one of these situations where
like it's some kind of minor trespass or
whatever and then you're you're let go
it's not even necessarily that charges
are dropped off and they're like never
even filed and she's wrapping that up
here
people who were identified as having
committed specific crimes not just being
in the area and maybe staying and
crossing a police line people who were
in there people who were doing stuff
it's a completely different situation so
the first question is are her numbers
even right in any way
and then it's what are what are we
really comparing here anyway
what's the difference there everyone
well okay I just explained it to you
I'll tell you for the BLM antifa riots
and violence the victims were the
American people and communities and
cities all across our country but on
January 6 you know who the victim was it
was the capital and the members of
Congress inside members my question is
this why is this Congress obsessed with
itself and cares nothing about the
American people this is a two-tier
justice system that should never exists
it is a two-tier justice system it's
just not the two tiers she thinks entry
and I'm fed up with it and so are
Americans all over the country now let's
skip ahead a little bit I guess to when
she took questions just to see kind of
what's up with that look at this our
plan is to be here with you our plan
earlier today was to travel out to the
original breach site and the places
where some of these videos were captured
but we do not have plans this evening
for that yes ma'am
said that the victims here I can't hear
a word they're saying
your reactions when you saw the footage
um the police officers being assaulted
and if you have any words for them today
a year after uh yeah I'll say the same
thing I've said all year long I'll say
the same thing I said starting that day
it was appalling and I want to know why
the National Guard was not outside the
capitol I am furious at that and I want
you to know that members well I mean ask
Trump and definitely the speaker of the
house she knew that there was going to
be violence that day president Trump
requested oh now she admits there was
violence okay the National Guard so did
others they knew things were going to
happen but for some reason they thought
that Optics would look bad if they had
the National Guard there yes as a
freshman member of Congress only a few
days on the job yeah I'm angry the
National Guard guard wasn't out there
and they left the Capitol Police as
sitting dots to have to to have to deal
with all of this and I would I would add
to that
what if those Capitol police officers
are victims of people like Ray Epps
absolutely what if they're victims of an
orchestrated effort by the FBI or other
law enforcement to increase the criminal
Acuity of that day so I would suggest
that every officer that was harmed that
day would would likely be served well by
answering these questions that attorney
general Garland and director Ray refuse
to answer
go ahead and ask her a question um
Senator Ted Cruz said yesterday
with a terrorism fact do you agree with
them
absolutely not I think Senator Cruz is
smart enough to know since he's an
attorney that no one's been charged with
terrorism just like no one has been
charged with Insurrection I think that
was very irresponsible of him to call
them terrorists and I'm I completely
disagree The Establishment will never
love you Ted you know you can uh you can
you can bend over uh at bended knee for
him oh my God they're just not going to
love you I think that was maybe an
effort by the good senator who we agree
with on many many things to to recast
himself in the eyes of uh of some of the
folks in your profession but you're gone
I didn't find it particularly factual or
sincere John
um what I heard Sarah Cruz say was that
he said the Democratic party wants all
Republicans to be seen as terrorists
that's what I heard when I spoke to him
but I wanted to ask you about the
attorney general he had a press
conference and we said the justice
department remains committed to holding
on January 6th perpetrators at any level
accountable by the way here's a good
comment via Super Chat all those people
do they truly believe what they are
spewing logic facts and the truth are
dead yeah I think there's a mix I think
there are some people who say this stuff
because they do believe it and I think
there are people who say this stuff
because they see it as what you're
supposed to say to show that you're on
the team
okay or otherwise criminally responsible
for the assault on our democracy we will
follow the facts where we what do you
make of that press conference the
Attorney General speaking out being
asked about Merrick Garland he was very
frustrating for me as a member of the
Judiciary Committee uh because the
Attorney General wouldn't answer
Congressman Thomas Massey's direct
question about where the facts in the
law land uh you know we're worried that
this might not be a crime so much as it
is a cover-up in in some circumstances
getting extremely conspiratorial uh Hey
chat who's Ray Epps Ray Epps is a guy
that some people like Matt Gates say was
an FBI operative creating the Trump
riots Gates mentions victims what about
Matt Gates victims those are alleged
victims Hillary alleged victims I want
to say thanks to nrz Luna the Hoosier
Daddy and Ms frazzled for the twitch
Prime subscriptions also want to say a
huge thank you to Mary Graham who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code Obama
and Douglas Lane who just signed up on
my website with the coupon code wow22
numbers 58 and 59 today very much
appreciate it all right we're not going
to watch the whole thing let's skip
ahead a little bit and see what else
they're up to on January 6 is the only
thing that that just rains the
discussion here's something for you all
what if the FBI was involved what if Ray
Epps and and what he was doing and this
man that was on the scaffolding and John
Sullivan and other Bad actors like them
what if that caused a member of the
press to get killed what would you all
be saying about that so what how what
kind of responsibility would you be
placing on the FBI or any kind of other
Federal agency if a member of the press
had been killed that day because of
violence that they had had cause to
action I mean I think this is a this is
a serious question you all work here
every single day just like we do you
walk these Halls this is this is the
place where you you gather information
and and do your job so you're saying
safety was also at risk that day too and
if our federal government was involved
in doing so I think that's something
that you should be very upset about and
she is poisonous huh
I'm sorry we're not familiar with that
particular case one of the cases
for throwing a fire extinguisher we're
not here to litigate any particular case
where no one's lawyer or no one's
Advocate we're here to speak to the
conditions that existed on that day to
the to the Civil Rights of people who
have been deprived access to Medical
Care religious services but we're not
going to get into the facts of any one
particular defendant
um you know we have brought video
evidence to display to you in the world
and we think that those are the just
because of just because you have a video
doesn't mean it's evidence of anything
in particular specific cases that that
would probably warrant the most thorough
ridiculous yes well right that's what
I'm showing you but but you're here
talking about about a case that I don't
know that we weren't involved in
adjudicating yes
and if Republicans take back the house
what kind of Investigations might you
launch involving this or any other sort
of related issues well we're going to
encourage Republican leadership to
utilize the January 6th committee
correctly to answer the questions oh
give me a break all right so he's
pathetic so this is this is this was
their response this is what they did
let's now go back over to the rally in
support of the Trump rioters this is how
many trumpists in Florida are
commemorating one year since the riots
by supporting the rioters exactly yes
yes what's your name Mike Mike right
side broadcasting network we're live
right now on YouTube We're on
our right side broadcasting airport
young man know what's going on that's
just wonderful why just use my eyes and
ears and I pay attention just a smart
young man
tell what's happening I interpret it for
myself because I'm smart enough to do
that I can give my goddamn brain yeah
yeah as we all should be doing but yeah
thank you so much for talking to us we
appreciate it
[Music]
oh no
Telegram and it's not censored oh my God
[Music]
look at this
she's saying they're they are this
telegram is how the disinformation is
spreading this is amazing
[Music]
oh I started broadcasting on there
on there be an app can you imagine live
coverage of this event any Trump rally
past present or future
um everything else articles we have
amazing writers on our website you can
find that all through the app but we're
also on telegram as well and getter
follow us right
wow there's this whole subculture it's
very very interesting and scary if you
just Google rsbn that that'll bring it
up to you yeah all right thank you
thank you oh thank you so much
well well I remove my sunglasses I think
we're getting close to Sunset I think it
sets around 5 30. and all right so we'll
check back in on that and see see what's
going on now it's all it's all very very
disturbing for sure
um thanks to Robert Robert saying via
Super Chat Happy New Year love you my
brother appreciate it appreciate
everybody who's here
um upcoming things that we know are
going on Tuesday January 11th 6 p.m
Eastern we will be doing the first of
2022 David Pacman show chess tournament
you can pre-register by joining our
chess club this is free at
davidpackman.com chess here it is
um Saturday January 15th we will be
streaming this lunatic right wing Rally
from Arizona among many of the speakers
is Donald Trump but also I believe
um
I think Michael Flynn is expected to
speak maybe Mike pillow I'm not really
sure so those are two streams that are
certainly upcoming
um but there will be there will be
others Richard says can we get producer
Pat a getter account yeah getter getter
is pretty weaponized
thanks to Ryan shank Ryan just signed up
on my website joinpakman.com using the
coupon code Obama
and his new member number 60. I invite
you to sign up guys listen
um what we do is mostly funded by you so
if this is your first time here or your
10th time or your 100th time I would
love for you to sign up on our website
joinpakman.com every day you get the
show six hours earlier than everybody
else there's nothing better than other
people getting screwed that's a joke
this is a left-wing show not a right
wing show uh but in all seriousness you
get the bonus show you get the show
early commercial free all these
different things and you can use the
coupon code obamna or the coupon code
wow22 both work both work and we
appreciate everybody using both of those
hardcore staunch Patriots or not people
that like what they have they like their
freedom they want to be in charge of
their own lives stand up and take their
country back
the true minority in this country are
the politicians the people who are
running the country
Towers
not following he's he's attacking people
in the Ivory Towers Trump owns a dozen
Ivory Towers it feels like we're at an
actual Trump rally just with the
soundtrack just with the music you got
Gloria playing right now
our CEO Joe seals that's his personal
favorite song he's watching right now
he might be dancing in the studio oh my
God but it's you know speaking of
rallies make sure you're tuned in next
Saturday As Trump will be holding his
first rally yeah
um Gary says what happened to Gates
being investigated for sex trafficking
underage girls how does he still have a
platform we're still waiting to see what
ultimately is going to happen with the
charges against Matt Gates I don't have
an answer for you I mean I just we just
don't know we don't we don't know
um things still calm as uh the Sun is
setting in Washington DC it looks very
likely that we're going to be getting
through today without uh violence in
Washington DC which is a really really
great thing we're glad about that of
course we are very very much glad about
that and that was our hope all along but
no current word on what to expect as far
as charges against Matt Gates go they
were for a long time expected to be any
day and it's been a while and you you
know how it is with a lot of these guys
there's just there are not consequences
the consequences just never happen when
Trump endorsed him that took him through
the roof as far as support put him on
the radar of a lot of Voters who were
undecided and the rest was history I
mean look at the work that he's done in
four years so we have to reelect him and
Trump will be a big part of that and the
same could be said for other Governors
and other politicians congressmen
Senators across the United States
so elections it is interesting you're
starting to see a lot of trump 2024
flags with the slogan take America back
as opposed to as opposed to refreshing
make America great again or make America
great again again they're going with
take America back
Super Chat from Johnny manogue Gloria
used to be one of my go-to drag Lip Sync
songs guess I have to take it out of my
repertoire I don't know I mean yeah I I
don't know how many musical decisions
need to be made on on this basis
necessarily but it's certainly something
to consider in this corner
here in
[Music]
plenty of times and people are lined up
to get a glimpse of him as he may drive
by for a second time today he may drive
by
[Music]
oh that's child abuse
it's really easy to feed off
a little better energy people are very
people are you know with all the turmoil
and all the yeah these are very very
sick people wanting a glimpse of their
dear leader uh and Matt jaded says
imagine being against Elites but voting
for a guy who announced his campaign
saying I'm really rich I I know I trust
me trust me I know the absurdity of it
it is completely nuts completely and
totally nuts uh it's not uh it
it belies credulity was there a sorrow
sign you're smiling oh are you shooting
of your heart we are live right now
[Music]
right now we are live right now yes
where are you from we are from New
Jersey oh okay yeah and what brings you
down here to this street lady he meant
where are you really from
uh actually we we are going to move here
so we bought a house here yeah nice what
made you decide to leave New Jersey for
Florida
[Music]
yeah it's a freedom is a red state New
Jersey is too much blue
and there's so many Democrats uh the
climate of crap and here I feel so much
a lot of freedom yeah I can choose I can
choose to live the way that I evolved
what couldn't you'd see if I were this
guy I would be below if I was competent
I would be saying what couldn't you do
in New Jersey that you can do here
that's the most interesting possible
question based on what she said and then
see what she says it's turned red
remember the November election yeah but
I there's some if the election flawed
the the system and if the problem
doesn't be solved I think Democrats will
use the the rigged system just to steal
the election this is painful it is it's
like all these people with a glancing
understanding of even what the the bad
talking points are no
[Music]
no I'll flip the result so we don't know
why and also a lot of my friends from
New Jersey they are crazy
losing their job because they don't want
to take a jab oh my God
apply for the religions of Freedom
religious exemption but it didn't get
approved Dear God they've been lay off
and so it's cool also for the kids to
take the vaccine and we are not against
a vaccine itself we are against the
mandate
right if you give up one step they're
going to come over to you for another
step it's funny because even that where
it's like they're late being laid off
because they're required to be
vaccinated they're not against the
vaccine they're only against the
requirement fine but if they've been
vaccinated they wouldn't be getting laid
off so it's like it's an incoherent
talking we're against vaccines at all
they're against mandates
but if you're against even them but they
were laid off not for being against the
Mandate they were being laid they were
laid off for not having the vaccine
against the vaccine or mandates you're
against vaccines altogether and you're
an anti-vaxxer if you wave the American
flag and you were in Washington DC on
January 6th you're an insurrectionist
you're a domestic terrorist
doing the protests peacefully right
right and all these Lily says via Super
Chat I watched the Insurrection with you
a year ago I appreciate your coverage as
always thank you very much I appreciate
that also want to say a big thank you to
Lee somebody who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code Obama Obama
and his new member number 61. I am
riveted by this interview I have to tell
you and it's it's always a complete
inversion isn't it because they're
they're pretending to care about the
people the capitol police officers who
died after after January 6 but we know
that they're just standing on their
graves because it helps them serve a
purpose but they said nothing about the
what 25 people who died lost their lives
during the George Floyd rise of 2020.
like nobody in America can deny that
that happening yet politicians in the
media they say nothing about it and the
opinion force that like you can still
you can steal anything and that is under
950 dollars and with no crime no
criminal but if you if you are raising
American flag they they call you
betrayed her what is that the definition
is if the depiction betrayed her is that
you love American Pride then I don't
mind it you just have to change the
definition all over pretty interesting
talking point absolutely I hope you
enjoy your time in Florida I think
you're gonna love it quite a bit more
than New Jersey yeah yeah sure yeah
it is I've been here for five years now
these are these interviews are
fascinating weather best beaches best
governor oh my God you gotta love it we
got to keep it like this yeah yeah
absolutely yeah well thank you so much
God bless yeah don't let any foreigners
get into Florida we got to keep it like
this she says we've got quite a few
people out here we've interviewed
several people and to my surprise not
many people want to talk about what
happened on January 6th what that's not
surprising at all that's not surprising
at all car wash freak says 2022 we need
to take these Republicans seriously the
threat of our democracy is real let's
put idealism for a moment I'm not
exactly sure what you're saying but I
think I get the gist of it and I agree
with it completely I agree with it
absolutely 100
I want to say thanks to
oh no I don't have any other twitch
people to think well that's okay the
White House coming from Congress they're
tired of the policies that have
destroyed everyone's lives you know we
had a Biden voter
riding by multiple times and from the
flag waves I've been to here in Florida
I've been to quite a few you would have
Biden voters driving by saying all right
we're gonna wait until there's another
interview but there are a bunch of super
chats JF says sir given your recent
Praise of mandarins I would like to
bring to your attention the annual
Mountain Mandarin Festival held in
Northern California that sounds like a
raucous event Les Pearson says one year
ago I mentioned the UK looked on in
horror nothing has changed bro luckily
it's only half a block
half a block I don't know what that
means oh this protest is only half a
block I guess is what you mean yeah
um yeah that's that's fair
we we do I mean we have a different
president now for sure that's that's
certainly a difference
uh oh people asking how my finger is
doing yeah I cut off the tip of my
finger on Sunday night it's doing a lot
better it's doing a lot better but it
was it was a very clean cut I mean I
what I realized is I don't need knives
that are that sharp for cooking
so I'm now going to be using a less
sharp knife
um it was it was pretty it was pretty
ugly it was pretty ugly
um but I'm doing I'm doing okay A little
bit of the nail too it's it's not a good
I recommend not doing it welcome to Mike
Cloutier who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code wow 22. I
really appreciate that very much let's
see if we can get one more interview in
here
[Music]
good people out here
[Music]
isn't um isn't Axel Rose a completely
anti-trump left Winger who would be
disgusted
that Guns and Roses songs are playing
here
I mean it's it's beyond parody quite
frankly thanks to mark for the 20
Australian dollar Super Chat very much
appreciate that
um and a few other people sending
elements of support let's see who else
they're going to chat with here
that's one of many ways to support us we
always tell you about our website of
course
rspnetwork.com forward slash donate and
of course our physical address where you
can mail checks and cash donations Etc
with our merch we have hats t-shirts
backpacks
um I believe we still have battery
charges we have a bunch of different
things on there go check out RSP battery
chargers that's something I should be
looking at Trump's tweets what's that
shirt Trump won wow that woman is
delusional very very sick the physical
address is 1550 Opelika Road Suite
these folks are the picture of Health if
they got coveted I'm sure they'd be fine
it would be great if he interviews the
woman in the mask and gloves about why
she's wearing that I would love that
there are people back behind this lineup
of
clouds here
behind the vehicles on the other side
here
[Music]
again it's not a ton of people just
because of this being a
parking lot it's not a ton of people
because it's completely idiotic to be
here supporting the rioters
[Music]
it's going to get a little bit of break
from the traffic and stuff
traffic and the music oh please talk to
this guy
[Applause]
love it good crowd out here
good crowd
you know
I don't want my country back I'm getting
tired of this I'm so fed up you know I
talk about these things on my YouTube
channel okay all right guys that's gonna
do it so we got through the day I
believe now that the sun has set in
Washington DC we got through the day
without violence on the one-year
anniversary of January 6th we watched
Biden's speech we watched Trump's
triggered reaction we read it we watched
the Marjory Taylor green Matt Gates
response it was completely off topic and
we seem to have gotten through the day
but before we go I want to say a huge
thank you to Dustin Brash who just sent
I believe this is what we call the big
boy I don't think you can send a bigger
than 500 Super Chat we've never seen it
before Dustin says in all caps with a
500 Super Chat hello everyone please
stop and wake up I don't think any of
this is Pleasant for anyone anymore
at some point someone has to wake up and
stop all of this Insanity before it
drives everyone past the point of no
return please just stop and listen and
try to understand each other Dustin with
a very expensive and very powerful
message of peace love unity and
bipartisanship sent in what could not
possibly be bigger capital letters
Dustin we appreciate you
and uh really I'm thrilled for your
support I also want to say thanks to
Tracy Sutton who just signed up on my
website with the coupon code Obama Obama
and that is going to do it for today's
stream oh sorry and thanks to Shanna
makes for the twitch Prime subscription
as well thanks everybody the programming
will continue we have Clips we have all
of it the podcast is out it's all
happening thank you for joining me and
we'll see you very very soon
foreign